hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to another oculus rift video
I found a few more games that you guys
are gonna enjoy that actually work with
the new oculus rift and then actually
follow head tracking and this one in
particular is interesting because well I
mean you just got to see it it's
freaking brick breaker on steroids on
and on LSD because it's insane now I
actually played it a bunch because it
was just plain fun and I don't have my
head oh wait a minute hang on I don't
have my headphones on but so I can't
hear the electronic music pumping in my
ears so the basics is and this one
actually takes advantage of a lot of the
features of the oculus rift in terms of
head tracking motion and movement over
there so I give me doing my shimmy while
I actually just play the entire game and
as you can so I'll come back here oh
there we go the thing whatever I was
doing I think I blew up the universe but
I'm not gonna worry about that I'm
having fun the other thing I learned is
that you can actually tap the side of
the oculus rift to select something if
you need to so it's like it's like
clicking with the mouse except you don't
need to actually click the mouse so you
can keep your hands up here now this
game this is the last level that I
played before I ice decided that this
game was just too awesome not to record
okay and like brickbreaker it gets a lot
faster once it gets into it so you just
kind of bear with me it's like try to
get this in that's really weird because
I'm holding my hands in front of my face
and I can't see my hands and that's a
really disorienting thing but this is
just the coolest I mean I know you guys
aren't experiencing the vibe oh god damn
it on the worst I'm just the worst game
player ever but you guys can't see or
experience this for what it is but oh my
god it's just the coolest thing ever
oh just an electic isn't that just an
epileptic attack waiting to happen
sorry about the bright colors everyone
but man
this is insane I got sparks flying into
my face all the time that I I'm kind of
twitching her from because I feel like I
need a I am shooting lasers out of my
eyes oh my god this is every little
kid's dream I am okay hang on I gotta
pick an accident yes shooting lasers out
of my eyes oh my god I'm sorry I'm
geeking out to an extreme here but okay
so the white bricks are power-ups oh
well the white bricks are explosions
actually that's what they are they're
they're power-ups are go okay okay okay
calm down
oh hello apparently I'm in a galaxy well
apparently I'm about to lose I gotta pay
attention to the game okay that's oh
never mind I don't need to pay attention
at all I'm just gonna win automatically
because I'm such a badass why am i
flying through a Cuban space am i in a
space butthole is this what the TARDIS
flies through every time it goes in time
another space butthole okay all lasers
lasers don't roll okay well apparently
everything's just gonna blow i won
somehow I won the game okay moving on
I'm not gonna question it
come on tap you [ __ ] oh this power up
down there I'm gonna get it oh oh lasers
why do I even need anything else I just
got the lasers lasers do it for me oh no
oh I saw my lasers
ball go away as much as I love hitting
balls with my face or them going in the
general de facility of my face I would
much rather shoot lasers out of my
eyeballs it's so weird it's like it's
like some unconscious thing I'm it's
such a disconnect I'm playing the game
without actually using my hands are
pushing any buttons
I'm just looking and it's happening
that's like amazing
this is incredible I love this this is
fantastic
I don't need to do any oh is that this
guy can't say okay what is that whoa my
ball has evolved I don't know what it
evolved into but it turned into some
spherical plasmoid orb I don't think
that's good
rookie this is normal an or you come
your tits down there a little bit I see
how this is a shorter uh it's a shorter
hard huh
if I could talk English it would be
there well I got lightning reflexes of a
mongoose crossed with a cat oh no no no
no somehow it actually is a little bit
better because with the with the eyes
you know there is no latency down to the
Hana itself precise controlling I mean
you spend your whole life looking at
stuff so why does that not explain the
how it could be good going too fast here
you need to slow down there boy write
down the angle over that way
okay oh no this is not what I wanted
okay stop oh what happened where is it I
can't see it oh don't do this I mean I
can't see it
where'd he go I don't know where it is
okay good angle wait a minute wait a
minute oh oh oh my god it turned into a
ping-pong paddle paddle ball whatever
it's called oh oh okay here I go
the American flag this is about as
American as it can get firing lasers out
of my eyeballs while saluting the weird
flag I got here
oh no no no you're not doing this to me
Oh do not turn the world upside down I'm
not ready for this okay no no no no
world is spinning all brady's big okay
all right I'm gonna I'm gonna die I'm
gonna die how I die I'm gonna die stop
moving seriously stop over the world oh
okay all right stop reading stops
reading please stop pinning stop
spinning
stop spinning so I would like it stopped
I'd like to get off the roller coaster
now hold on my teddy bear I don't want
my blanket I want to really close my
eyes only get that freaking power up I
want to go home wanna snuggle up and
watch dr. Phil and The Price is Right
drew Carey please cut me into steps like
I'm literally gonna throw up if you die
if you do not stop I'm going to throw up
oh god please just hit the damn thing
thank you oh god substrate please
oh god don't do that again Oh take it
off the room was spinning and I was not
that did not feel good on the brain all
right so anyway oh so anyway that was
just one game that I got to work I have
another one that you guys are gonna love
I know it don't happen Oh what excuse me
oh I think that was me gaming over
go play game overs what okay whoa okay
what is this
when does this turn into a horror game
[Music]
holy crap what happened
okay I'm just gonna I'm gonna go now I'm
gonna go all right so anyway I have
another game I know you guys loved my
neighbor totoro the game they actually
have another one for spirited away I
love this movie and I know a lot of you
guys it's one of the best movies ever
made so please enjoy this next oculus
rift experience hello hello you're not I
never know what these guys are called
they're like dust mites but oh they're
so cute Hannah are you like and I don't
know if I can crouch but they're
carrying the rocks I mean they're
carrying coal obviously into the furnace
but oh god that is so cute
okay yo little guy you lost you don't
have anything what are you doing you
don't have anything oh you know oh yes
right go back you're not fooling anybody
you need to go back jeez hey yo Bob why
yapple going hello sir sir sir I'm a
little girl I'm lost in oh oh you are a
little creepy are you doing loading over
there I'm over here
why don't you ignore me I'm a little
girl lost in this world you need to help
me all right whatever you do your thing
I'm gonna do mine oh oh okay alrighty
then
that's cool oh look how cool that is
it's your hi can you help me can you
help me I don't know how much it's
involved in this particular demo but
it's really cool the attention to detail
that they put into this I mean God well
I'm watch this movie in a while either
hello
some weird lady gonna pop through that
door demon lady
I don't keep looking over me and mine
having a little fear help okay whatever
can I like do the thing with the thing
and let me I need to do this thing
where's the dust mite that is a rock
that's too big I want to help you I want
to help you throw it in please okay I
guess that's it I don't really don't
know what else to do I've actually kind
of peered in the walls and I didn't see
anything
but you guys are adorable you keep doing
what you're doing
oh I love you guys but either way thank
you guys again for another awesome video
this oculus rift is amazing I know it's
gonna take at least a week for some
really good horror games to come out but
as soon as they do let me know in the
comments below I'm gonna hold off on
making another video until then but
either way this is awesome this is
incredible I freaking love this to death
so thanks again everybody for watching
and as always
[Music]
I'm gonna call you tiny box tip you're
gonna come up and it is basic tiny box